meanwhile in the u.s a sudden wave of
thousands of migrants has sparked a
humanitarian crisis at the u.s mexico
border the texas border town of del rio
is struggling to cope with the massive
influx of people seeking safety and
prosperity in the united states
more than 10 000 people
living under a bridge
this is the scene at the u.s mexico
borders thousands of migrants from haiti
many of whom began their trek overland
as far away as colombia when their long
and often dangerous journeys stopped
at the international bridge
connecting del rio in texas to mexico's
ciadad acuna
the situation is becoming desperate
we now have
one third of the population of the city
of davio texas in a confined space under
the city of del rio international bridge
so that said
i had thought that the alarm was set on
monday this is setting
the nuclear bomb alarm that this is no
longer
sustainable acceptable
overwhelmed by the surge of asylum
seekers u.s department of homeland
security announced it will use a
pandemic related authority to
immediately expel migrants back to haiti
without allowing them an opportunity to
claim asylum
but with the promise of a better life in
sight migrants refuse to give up their
dreams of a new life in america
i don't want to be deported
if i'm deported now
i'll die in haiti why
because there's no security in haiti
with no better option than to hunker
down and hope
scores of people waited back and forth
across the rio grande into mexico to
resupply buying water food diapers
before returning to the texas side
and the uncertain weight
under the bridge
you